my name is Marcel and I'm partially a
shelf and I have a lot of other great
qualities as well
sometimes I find my mind wandering
thinking what would my family think
do you think they could be out there
let's forget about being afraid just
Adventure okay Lynn let's do it Marcel
and his nanakani have been separated
from their family who have disappeared
in a mysterious tragedy Marcel is a
really developed individual he has a
really large capacity for matters of the
heart hi everybody it's Marcel I'm
recording this video because I'm looking
for my family
I think with Dean it was again like a
meeting of the minds he had an approach
that we had never I had never done any
other director had made this movie it
would be a disaster he's pushed us to do
things that we would say no way you
can't do that if a traditional
stop-motion director had come in and
done this it would have been ordinary
the way I've been describing the
animation process is imagine how any
movie with a CG character gets made you
shoot the live action plates and VFX
artists using computers model and
composite the CG character into the live
action footage right now imagine that
instead of a computer what you have is a
second shoot a stop-motion shoot and
it's physical it's on a stage and
everything has to match perfectly with
the live action footage that you shot
wow with stop-motion it's charming and
it it's Charming because it's vulnerable
right from the stud I think the
challenge for us was to maintain that
quality that Dean had created it was a
handmade quality
this was a Sunday and everybody gets
together and we all Watch 60 Minutes
every single object of Marcel interacts
with has to be recreatable and
animatable the couch for example you
have to shoot that couch and then you
have to take that on an animation stage
and essentially gut it and fill it with
materials that look exactly identical
but can be animated
[Applause]
oh
these characters are real small so they
don't have any weight when the
characters jump down and they land on
that seat something has to push them
into the ground so what we've done is
we've created an apparatus that sits in
the sofa cushions that an animator can
then pull down and push up and we have
maybe 35 points on each cushion to be
able to push up and pull down
I cried from the beauty
they're making me blush
what I love about Marcel is that he
understands he knows trauma and loss and
grief really intimately but that is
completely separate from his total
optimism okay so it actually doesn't
even seem that big I mean it's big but
what we just need to do is get up high
and then maybe we'll be able to spot his
car
but that's more like
I think I'm gonna cry there's fountains
in the lake there's a lot of places to
get tattoos psychic love expert
wow I bet wow
in this car shot you know we shot real
footage of us driving and when we went
around this corner in the live action
plate the light obviously changed
because the orientation of the sun
changed so then Eric had to examine that
movement and then recreate what the
shadow movement would have been on stage
so meet your own needs a new feature I
can see it now yeah exactly baby baby
[Music]
let me get to this point in the shot
this Shadow starts moving which required
you know a motion control mechanism
that's sliding the lights around too and
these are also super impressive too all
these little flickers and stuff all line
up with you know where we passed a palm
tree or whatever
yeah it's psychotic
times a day do you throw up in your car
yeah so this is stage zero and this is
where we've done all of our ice skating
shots Marcel skates by putting dust on a
coffee table and then everyone can skate
around but this is all like real dust so
we have to be extremely careful when
we're animating
because there's no going back this is
really good especially for such a little
one but you know what it is she has
that thing that's like when you're young
you have no fear because you haven't
injured yourself yet you don't even know
what risk is you just Zoop around all
the time and I'll pop it up no no no no
no I don't think so don't you want to
pop it up no no
no say jam you say damn Jam
I think he looks really good
The Voice like sounds like this and
that's what he sounds like
Marcel is real
they shouldn't be thinking about all the
technical things that went into making
him real when they see him on the screen
he's there he's a real little creature
who's interacting with Dean
what
[Music]
I'm a little longer here with you the
stage makes him feel good
he needs that what I didn't see it
coming about it was sort of the extent
of the fandom and the passion that and
and the closeness that people felt about
Marcel totally overwhelming but
um really really moving at the same time
we've gotten lucky enough to work with
people who really like respond to the
material on a very personal level it's
the most handcrafted way you can make a
film you're actually making every frame
individual frame by hand and the result
is Magic
[Applause]
Marcel's just kind of like doing his
thing
and for us that is inspirational it just
has so much heart you know it's like we
need that now everybody needs that so
much now it's wonderful yeah it's a
broad spectrum of emotions
yeah yeah I still cry at the anime
pin like over a year there's an
emotionality to stop motion I think
because we see ourselves in it we see
other humans made this
[Music]
I think he's really handsome
he's really small